[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
depuis bruxelles depuis le quart du
parlement européen dans ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo et bien nous
allons ouvrir comme chaque semaine les
portes de l'europe
et voici le programme comment redonner
de la vivacité à nos démocraties
européennes faut-il pour se faire
réformer nos institutions nous prendront
la direction de l'italie qui a choisi de
réduire d'un tiers le nombre de ses
parlementaires une bonne chose
vraiment je poserai la question à mes
invités en plateau
mais avant tout ce qu'il ne fallait pas
louper dans l'actualité européenne cette
semaine du retour du parti nationaliste
irlandais le thin fine à la crise
politique en allemagne s'est résumé pour
vous comme chaque semaine par aurélie
d'afas
en irlande la réunification revient sur
le devant de la scène politique
deuxième force du pays depuis les
élections législatives début février le
parti républicain irlandais chine fine a
pour objectif la réunification de la
république d'irlande avec la province
britannique d'irlande du nord
sa dirigeante marie lou mcdonald estime
que le bric site a changé la donne et
qu'un référendum pourrait avoir lieu sur
l'île sous trois ans elle a demandé à
l'union européenne de soutenir le projet
de réunification de l'irlande
la capacité du chine fine à peser sur
l'avenir du pays dépendra de l'issue des
négociations en cours pour former une
coalition gouvernementale
matteo salvini est renvoyé devant la
justice accusé par un tribunal de catane
d'abus de pouvoir et de séquestration de
personne
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur avait
interdit à un navire transportant des
migrants de débarquer dans un port
italien
les 116 personnes présentes à bord
s'étaient retrouvés bloqués en mer une
semaine
le sénat a décidé de lever l'immunité
parlementaire de matteo salvini
remettant son sort entre les mains de la
justice
en cas de procès ils encourent jusqu'à
15 ans de réclusion
[Musique]
il ya en effet un affaiblissement de
l'occident divergences entre le
secrétaire d'état américain mike pompéo
et le président français la conférence
sur la sécurité de munich a pris des
airs de règlement de comptes entre
européens et américains
désaccord sur l'état de l'occident et la
tendance au repli affiché par donald
trump
mais aussi sur la chine washington fait
pression sur l'union pour qu'elle
n'accorde pas à l'entreprise chinoise
huawei l'accès à ces réseaux de
télécommunication 5g les européens
tiennent pour l'instant une position
intermédiaire pas d'interdiction mais
des règles de sécurité séisme politique
en allemagne
suite aux élections en thuringe les
conservateurs de la cdu ou se sont
associés à l'afd
le parti d'extrême droite pour élire le
président de la région
une alliance interdite selon les lignes
directrices du parti d'angela merkel
c'était un mauvais jour pour la
démocratie
cette journée a rompu avec les valeurs
et les convictions de l'accès des taux
masqué meurisch démissionnera en moins
de 24 heures mais cette élection ne
restera pas sans conséquence elle
précipite la démission d'un degré tu
craques aaron bauer successeur désigné
d'un gala merkel au sein de la cd ou
d'inga politique foudre autre nom et
denis des prochaines législatives la
première force politique du pays se
retrouvent sans chef de file pour
succéder à angela merkel à la tête du
gouvernement depuis 2005
m
très directe fonnière bienvenue vous
êtes chercheur à l'université libre de
belgique spécialiste de l'allemagne et
des relations avec l'union européenne
on vient de le voir dans le sujet le
président de thuringe a été élu avec les
voix de l'afd une première depuis 1945
est ce qu'on peut vraiment parler en
allemagne de séisme politique
il y a sans aucun doute une crise
politique en allemagne je nuancerais
l'idée du racisme pour deux raisons
d'abord c'est pas de nouveau c'est pas
soudain l'afd a émergé sur la scène
politique il ya dix ans et a gagné
presque toutes les élections aura du
moins grandi à chaque passage aux urnes
depuis son arrivée sur la scène
politique allemande
donc ce n'est pas un séisme soudain par
contre c'est une crise pour les partis
politiques qui ont perdu le contrôle de
la dynamique au parlement du land de
thuringe jeta coup quelque chose est
arrivé qu'ils n'avaient pas prévu
ils ont perdu le contrôle et d'autre en
plus il semblerait que les parties
soient de moins en moins capable
d'imposer les tabous les interdit la
pratique politique acceptable donc on
est là dans une crise de partie avant
tout est ce que cela veut dire que l'afd
donc le parti d'extrême droite en
allemagne il est normalisée sur la scène
politique allemande
quelque chose a changé il est plus
centrale il ya peu tabou n'est plus un
tabou
il ya encore de tabouk par exemple si on
compare à d'autres pays en europe
il ya encore un tabou pu prononcer en
allemagne nous sommes pas dans une
situation autrichienne par exemple la
réaction qui a eu la chute à kaka
le fait que le président élu s'est
retiré tout ça indique que le système
politique le corps politique a réagi et
a rechuté mais c'est très très difficile
de rétablir un tabou il a été brisé
on verra si la réaction a suffi pour le
rétablir
cette élection en thuringe elle met
également en effet vous l'avez tout
juste abordé en exergue la crise au sein
même de la td ou le parti conservateur
la succession d'angela merkel qui
s'ouvre dans les conditions un petit peu
chaotique la dauphine désignée qui donc
s'est retiré angela merkel elle a une
responsabilité dans cette crise interne
à la télé où cette crise est un produit
du fin de règne de angela merkel ça
c'est sur une responsabilité personnelle
c'est plus compliqué la transition au
sommet d'un parti au pouvoir est
toujours compliqué je vous rappelle que
angela elle même n'a pas été adoubé par
son prédécesseur mais qu'elle est
arrivée au pouvoir elle a saisi le
pouvoir du parti au sein d'une crise
grave à l'époque au sein de la cd ou
donc les transitions se font souvent
dans des contextes crise là le retrait
partiel dakkak à la dauphine a créé un
vide
des noms circulent la grande inconnue la
source d'instabilité d'incertitude est
en fait plus dans comment cette
transition va s'opérer maintenant dans
quel temps et de quelle façon
angela merkel on peut quand même dire
qu'elle est fragilisé comment peut
fonctionner encore le groupe
le couple franco-allemand outil demeure
tout de même un demain un moteur dans
l'union européenne
déjà avant la crise les commentateurs
remarquaient que le couple franco
allemand où le couple macron angela
merkel étaient difficiles il y avait des
caractères des objectifs politiques très
différents maintenant évidemment angela
est fragilisé et son parti est fragilisé
mais l'europe ce depuis longtemps n'est
plus construite par deux pays où un pays
mais par des coalitions
on verra donc probablement les
coalitions au sein de l'union que
championne elle soutenait l'allemagne
les porte parole de ces coalitions
seront d'autres pays par exemple dans
les questions budgétaires
les amis de l'austérité on voit déjà les
pays bas les api nandy prendre le
danemark prendre le relais le couple
franco-allemand ce n'est pas une
dynamique figé c'est une réalité
organique qui évoluent en fonction du
contexte
je vous propose même d'écouter un des
prétendants à la succession d'angela
merkel au sein d'accéder où qu'ils
aillent mythe déjà des regrets sur le
couple franco-allemand écouter
d'anatolie soir d'emmanuel macron a fait
le discours de la sorbonne avec des
propositions substantielles est
importante pour l'europe il répond ça
rennes aurait finalement engagé à ce
sujet nikon est ce qu angela merkel elle
a été trop timide sur les ambitions
européennes en tout cas souhaité par
emmanuel macron il faut garder à
l'esprit que quand le président macro
est arrivé au pouvoir
angela merkel avait déjà avec ses
collègues européens mener une énorme
réformes liées à la crise la zone euro
angela merkel a et les gouvernements
européens sortait d'une période des
normes réformes positives ou négatives
ça dépend de qui on demande et donc il y
avait un essoufflement politique à une
fatigue politique chez elle et en plus
s'approchait la fin du règne qui
maintenant se confirmer qui s'accélère
où le président macro et pour le couple
franco-allemand là par exemple la
personne que nous venons d'entendre et
le candidat qui est vu comme celui dans
la continuité d'angela faire écho aux
propositions de macron est un signal que
à nouveau régime à une cd aurait affirmé
une nouvelle dynamique pourrait avec
monsieur l'achète peut-être avec
d'autres impliqués aussi un engagement
avec la dynamite marque rond l'allemagne
c'est tout de même un modèle de
stabilité en europe par depuis plus de
dix ans est ce que avec cette crise
politique cela va fragiliser l'union
européenne l'union à tendance d'aller
des crises en crises auxquelles c'est un
système qui est résistant aux crises il
faut par ailleurs se rendre compte que
toutes choses par ailleurs garder le
système allemand est encore plutôt
stable comparé au nombre de ses voisins
enfin l'élément d'instabilité nouveau
pour le système allemand politique est
au niveau des landes
anciennement les invasions locaux les
régions avaient été dominés par un ou
deux parties là on voit à travers tous
les régions d'allemagne cd parlement
avait des coalitions de deux trois voire
quatre parties et donc le système
politique c'est déstabiliser s'est
fragmentée par le bas les coalitions au
niveau national et fédéral reste stable
avec quelles répercussions du coup pour
l'union européenne où pour la
construction européenne on peut pas le
dire encore c'est un certain tout
dépendra de quelles effet cette
instabilité au niveau cette
fragmentation au niveau local
aura au niveau fédéral en allemagne et
par conséquent au niveau européen merci
frédéric bonnet de nous avoir éclairé
sur la situation allemande et je vous
propose maintenant de prendre la
direction de l'italie
les députés italiens ont approuvé en
octobre dernier à une écrasante majorité
la réduction d'un tiers du nombre de
sièges parlementaires
une réforme souhaitée par le mouvement
populiste 5 étoiles qui pourrait
profondément transformé le paysage
politique italien
c'est un reportage de flora sauvage
[Musique]
c'était le cheval de bataille du
mouvement 5 étoiles adopté à une
écrasante majorité le 8 octobre dernier
le parlement italien va réduire
drastiquement le nombre de ses
parlementaires passant de 940 5 à 6 ans
le jour du vote devant les caméras luigi
di maio exulte c'est une immense
victoire pour le peuple et pour les
citoyens italiens à rome
la baisse du nombre de parlementaires
fait quasi l'unanimité dans ce bar une
institution du trastevere
l'un des quartiers populaires de la
capitale rares sont les opposants à
cette mesure qu il nous coûte trop cher
et est en plus il n'hésite pas assez
rapidement je pense que cette réduction
est positif je suis positive au credo
reste ya je crois que c'est une bonne
idée à ce qu'ils sont en maths et en
coûte trop cher 12 sauver non vraiment
ils sont faits pour certains - de
parlementaires c'est aussi moins deux
territoires représentés au niveau
national je ne crois pas que ce soit une
bonne chose car ça va nuire à la
représentation démocratique et cela va
nuire aussi à la représentation des
minorités au sein du parlement
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
que le nombre de parlementaires restent
stables
pour le mouvement 5 étoiles en perte de
vitesse la diminution du nombre de
députés et de sénateurs est une mesure
qui pourrait lui permettre de renouer
avec son électorat
selon cette députée du parti anti
système réduire d'un tiers le nombre de
parlementaires va générer des économies
conséquentes pour le budget de l'état
donc oui ce total avec cette réduction
on a estimé que l'on pourrait économiser
un milliard d'euros sur dix ans entre
les indemnités des députés et des
sénateurs mais aussi avec mais où les
coins que le parlement n'auraient pas en
ayant 345 parlementaire au moins et cela
va permettre d'avoir un rapport plus
direct entre les citoyens et leurs
représentants à l aller à l'été 2010 9
après la chute de la coalition entre le
mouvement 5 étoiles et la ligue de
matteo salvini
le parquet anti système fait de la
baisse du nombre de parlementaires la
condition non négociable de son alliance
avec le parti démocrate
initialement opposés à cette mesure les
sociaux-démocrates posent leurs
conditions
en échange de leur ralliement
aujourd'hui on a adhéré à la proposition
du mouvement cinq étoiles de red bull
monde parlementaire c'est une
proposition qui avait déjà été approuvé
par la majorité précédente meilleures
conditions nous voulons modifier la loi
électorale
nous allons également une révision du
règlement du parlement et on demande une
attention particulière pour donner plus
d'équilibré fair en plus jolie mais au
local du parti démocrate
les avis divergent ce soir là au fond de
cette ruelle de la capitale les
militants s'oppose farouchement à cette
réforme qu'il juge populistes
on va passer d'un député à 400 et de 3,5
un sénateur à 200 donc ça va faire une
réduction de 36% actuellement un
parlementaire pour soixante trois mille
cinq cents habitants sachant qu'en
france c'est un parlementaire pour
soixante dix mille habitants
mais avec cette réforme on va passer
d'un extrême à l'autre en ayant une
représentation très faible des six ans
même talent au référendum
je dois vous dire honnêtement que pour
la première fois de ma vie je vais voter
contre mon parti c'est une mesure
pourtant adopté par la formation à
laquelle j'appartiens depuis qu'elle est
née
c'est une décision que j'ai mûrement
réfléchie en réalité un coup cette
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
est évalué à quelques dizaines de
millions d'euros sur un budget total de
l'état de centaines de milliards
c'est pas ça qui va assainir les comptes
publics
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
déjà en 2016 lors d'un référendum
constitutionnel
matteo renzi avait tenté de réduire le
nombre de sénateurs
mais les italiens s'y était opposé car
ils craignent à une concentration des
pouvoirs
les électeurs sont appelés aux urnes le
29 mars pour valider définitivement la
baisse du nombre de parlementaires
en cas de victoire du oui au référendum
l'italie deviendra le pays d'europe avec
le plus petit nombre de représentants
élus proportionnellement à sa population
[Musique]
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir manuel
bompard bonjour vous êtes eurodéputés
français la france insoumise ici vous
siéger au sein du groupe la gauche
unitaire à vos côtés marc tarabella
eurodéputé belge au sein de l'alliance
progressiste des socialistes et
démocrates bonjour j'ai effacé avoue que
le type d'armes en eurodéputés roumaine
renie où le groupe centriste européen
bienvenue à tous les trois on vient le
voir dans le reportage cette réforme
elle est motivée notamment par les
économies qu'elle pourrait générer et
puis cela rendrait le travail des
chambres plus efficace marc tarabella
est ce que vous êtes convaincu par ses
arguments
si j'étais convaincu j'ai bien
évidemment et ça va dans le sens de ce
que veut le peuple mais peut-être
faut-il réduire c'est possible mais je
pense qu'il faut il ya du populisme dans
cette proposition pourquoi parce que
comme l'a dit l'un des derniers
intervenants
ça va faire des économies certes mais la
démocratie elle a un coût si on devait
transposer ça au niveau européen on peut
aussi diminuer noms de parlementaires on
ne serait plus cinq cents au lieu de 36
m oui c'est une idée mais aujourd'hui le
luxembourg est le plus petit pays en ont
si c'est si c'est le nombre minimal pour
avoir une représentation démocratique
suffisante d'ailleurs quatre partis sont
représentés notamment au grand duché du
luxembourg
et donc si la prochaine proposition
c'est aussi de diminuer les salaires des
parlementaires par deux
et si on met un référendum saf à 95 % de
oui est ce que c'est ça qui va changer
les choses qui va apporter du plus aux
citoyens parce que l'organisation du
référendum il faudrait déjà savoir
combien ça va coûter
rien pour approuver cette mesure est
donc la démocratie elle a un coût au
niveau européen on pourrait très bien
dire tout le monde parle anglais et on
fait l'économie de la tra delà de la
traduction certains voudraient faire ça
mais aujourd'hui le coût de la
démocratie notamment au niveau européen
c'est que chacun puisse parler sa langue
maternelle est donc la démocratie a un
coût et la représentativité de la
population et le lien au territoire doit
être assurée et donc il faut assumer le
coût de la démocratie mais ça reste
quand même la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires
une mesure populaire notamment aussi
parce qu'il ya un fossé qui s'est creusé
entre les politiques et les citoyens que
types d'armes en roumanie
c'est le cas aussi non donc en fait il
s'agit bien d'un symptôme c'est ce fossé
c'est à dire les gens et
tim que les parlementaires finalement
sont pas très utile puisqu'on trouve
qu'on est trop nombreux et puis ils
trouvent qu'ils ne font mal leur travail
je voudrais un vent de l'odet la parole
manuellement par qu'on compare un petit
peu ensemble le nombre de parlementaires
dans plusieurs pays en europe pour avoir
une idée un petit peu plus globale
un parlementaire pour cent seize mille
habitants en allemagne 1 pour 72 mille
en france
un parlementaire pour 76000 espagnol en
italie avant la réforme
on était à un parlementaire pour
soixante trois mille habitants - de
parlementaires allemands paraissent que
c'est la galère d'une meilleure
démocratie
non je crois pas moi je suis
radicalement opposé à cette proposition
il ya des arguments qui ont été déjà
donné la question du coût par exemple le
coup il faut le relativiser
et si on veut faire des économies dans
nos pays respectifs il ya plein de
manières de faire des économies je crois
pas que ça soit en réduisant le nombre
de parlementaires qu'on va en faire à en
france par exemple quand monsieur macron
supprimer l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune c'est 4 milliards en italie on
parlait de 1 milliard d'économies sur 10
ans donc je pense que tout ça et me
paraît pas raisonnable et puis comme ça
a été dit la democracia lincou d'oscar
n'a qu'à supprimer les élections ça
coûte de l'argent aussi d'organiser
d'imprimer des bulletins de vote etc
je pense que tout ça n'est pas nenê
n'est pas sérieux par contre je partage
l'idée que daria un symptôme et un
ressenti qui conduit à soutenir ce type
de proposition je pense en france en
l'occurrence peut-être pas le cas dans
tous les pays européens qu'il est aussi
motivée par le même coeur on a le
sentiment que les parlementaires ont
très peu de pouvoirs que le système est
très présidentiel et que finalement
l'assemblée nationale et une chambre
d'enregistrement
et donc si on veut répondre à cette
préoccupation je pense qu'on le fera
davantage en valorisant le rôle des
parlementaires que en en réduisant le
nombre
alors justement vous parlez de la france
parce qu'il n'ya pas qu'en italien qu'on
souhaite réduire le nombre de
parlementaires c'est également la
volonté du président français emmanuel
macron écoutez c'était devant les
parlementaires en juillet 2010 est un
parlement moins nombreux mais renforcé
dans ses moyens
c'est un parlement où le travail devient
plus fluide où les parlementaires
peuvent s'entourer de collaborateurs
mieux formés plus nombreux
c'est un parlement qui travaille mieux
c'est pourquoi
proposerait une réduction d'un tiers du
nombre des membres des trois assemblées
constitutionnel je suis convaincu que
cette mesure aura des effets favorables
pour la qualité générale du travail
parlementaire
clotilde armand il n'y a pas un revers
quand même assez un peu dangereux de
taper comme ça c'est effectivement sur
les parlementaires
nous ce que nous souhaitons faire c'est
également redonner de la crédibilité aux
parlementaires donc il faut moi je pense
qu'il faut accorder aux citoyens ce
qu'ils souhaitent et en même temps de
travailler sur la crédibilité
ce que nous avons fait il y a deux ans
et un collection de signatures pour
mettre un référendum devant le parlement
il s'agit d'interdire l'accès aux
fonctions publiques aux personnes
condamnés pénalement
donc nous avons un certain nombre de
grandes il a eu du nez les jb nous avons
un certain nombre d'élus ou de personnes
qui souhaiteraient telus qui ont eu des
soucis avec la justice notamment sur la
corruption vous savez que nous faisons
cette énorme nettoyage en roumanie nous
y tenons énormément
marc tarabella au delà de la réduction
du nombre des parlementaires est ce que
nos systèmes ils sont pas obsolètes
est-ce qu'il faut pas réformer nos
institutions dont les démonstrations
sans doute faut-il la démocratie doit
les malades aujourd'hui la
représentation démocratie démocratie est
malade elle est malade parce que
effectivement on dit qu'on a creusé un
fossé entre les élus et la population je
pense que tout dépend de la manière dont
au travail
mais toute façon la perception elle est
celle là est sans doute faut-il avoir
une dose de proportionnelle
une dose de participation citoyenne sans
doute pour moi je ne suis pas pour la
démocratie directe
parce que dit demander aux citoyens si
celles ci on va baisser l'impôt ils vous
disent oui leur majorité sans problème à
vendre il faut savoir repopulariser
l'imposent son service correctement et
il expliqué et donc mais qui est une
dose de consultation citoyenne prolonger
un exemple abouti en belgique pour
l'instant il ya plusieurs tentatives
c'est la communauté germanophone nombre
de langues allemand qui est très petit
neuf communes 70000 habitants à l'est du
pays qui a instauré une espèce de
conseils citoyens permanents tirés au
sort qui s'appuie sur des tirages au
sort des différents sujets sont d'autres
d'autres conseils sur des thématiques et
qui font remonter et à un moment donné
un dialogue entre les élus et ceux
conseils tirés au sort sont
représentatifs et qui peut aboutir à des
lois à des changements après un dialogue
et c'est probablement l'exemple le plus
abouti parce que le conseil permanent
manuellement par il faut tendre de plus
en plus vers ça au sein même de l'union
européenne il existe le droit de petits
soins le droit d'initiative citoyenne
c'est une bonne chose
foncia une bonne chose mais à mon avis
c'est très insuffisant parce que en
réalité au sein des institutions
européennes ce droit et n'est pas
forcément suivies d'effet c'est à dire
que la commission de gestion mis en
application je pense en tout cas que y
effectivement la démocratie est malade
et que clairement la solution elle passe
par une revalorisation du rôle des
parlementaires mais aussi par le fait
d'introduire des formes de démocratie
directe dans la démocratie
représentative ça veut pas dire passer à
un système de démocratie directe au
total moi je pense au référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ça existe dans
certains états européens
je pense à la possibilité de révoquer
les élus à mi-mandat ça ça n'existe pas
en europe mais certains états des états
unis d'amérique par exemple leur école
et c'est à dire si à mi-mandat un élu
n'a pas respecté ses engagements on
puisse dire bah ça s'arrête et puis on
organise une nouvelle élection faut du
coup sortir peut-être de l'immédiateté
parce que cela prend du temps de
consulter les citoyens
moi je pense que ce qui est important
c'est que ces citoyens s'approprient
finalement les institutions qui est des
nouveaux partis qui étaient partis avec
des des élus qui ne vont pas faire
carrière mais qui vont être spécialisés
dans un domaine mais qui vont rester
encore et dans la société qui vont être
élus pour un mandat pour demanda au plus
deux mandats c'est ce que nous
souhaitons dans notre parti et puis qui
retourne dans la dans la société civile
leur profession la classe politique est
une classe qui se reproduisent il reste
toute la vie qui est privilégiée qu'il
ya c'est ce sentiment il est partagé
dans bon nombre de pays européens
finalement oui oui les îles et il est
partagé et des fois pour des raisons
légitimes d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
les propositions de que vous faites que
vous formulez d'exemplarité de non-cumul
non renouvellement c'est des
propositions que je partage mais à mon
avis elles elles ne résolvent qu'une
partie du problème c'est à dire que
l'autre partie du problème c'est des
citoyens qui ont envie de pouvoir
participer au pouvoir de décision et
aujourd'hui le référendum d'initiative
stein par exemple en france
il est malheureusement consultatif c'est
à dire que vous vous devez avoir 1 4
million de signatures et un certain
nombre de parlementaires pour que le
projet soit examinée à l'assemblée
nationale je pense que c'est pas
suffisant
il faudra avoir une possibilité d'en
suite ça aboutit sur une consultation
directe du peuple au moins qu'on
améliore ses dispositifs là en france et
je m'arrête là président matheron avait
dit on va le descendre à 1 million mais
on est on a un exemple concret c'est
aéroports de paris qui est menacée de
privatisations il ya plus d'un million
de signatures aujourd'hui en france mais
pour l'instant il ya toujours pas de
référendum d'organiser ça c'est pour la
france marc tarabella est ce que les
institutions européennes et le parlement
au teint elles doivent aussi et bien se
transforment et évoluent et oui et
davantage parce que aujourd'hui l'europe
est un modèle en un peu en panne à bout
de souffle
mais c'est davantage il faut mettre les
responsabilités l'europe il ya trois
grandes institutions la commission qui
va pouvoir de proposition et puis en
codécision nous sommes les deux
législateurs les co législateur le
parlement et le conseil
donc les ans l'ensemble des
gouvernements représentés à bruxelles et
c'est le conseil le maillon faible de
l'union européenne aujourd'hui c'est
davantage de conseils que le parlement
alors toute une série de dossiers que ce
soit
l'afflux d'émigrants essayer de résoudre
l'accueil la commission et parlement
avait de bonnes propositions de
solidaires au niveau de l'europe c'est
le conseil et certains gouvernements
qu'ils n'en ont pas voulu
et donc les gouvernements iliad minorité
de blocage maintenant qu'ils font que si
le projet est à bout de souffle l'europe
à la carte qui ont inventé les
britanniques aujourd'hui à beaucoup de
pays qui aime l'europe à la carte pour
ça que schengen ya certains pays dans
l'euro il y en a d'autres et dans des
politiques plus ambitieuse on va
retrouver certains et pas d'autres
et aujourd'hui c'est sans doute cela
qu'il faut réformer le parlement
européen qui est directement élu il a
peu de pouvoir finalement il a un
pouvoir
je vous donne un exemple lorsque sur
certains dossiers comme le budget qui
est un point majeur dont voudrais avoir
le les moyens de notre ambition et ont
je pense qu'on reflète vraiment ce que
désirent les citoyens mais quand le
conseil qui est formé de 27 membres dont
chacun des membres a un pouvoir de veto
donc il faut que ce soit votée à
l'unanimité
c'est très difficile pour le parlement
une fois que 27 pays se sont mis
d'accord de bien nous le parlement n'est
pas d'accord parce que du coup les il
faudra à nouveau un nom de négociations
donc le parlement il est en relation
directe avec les citoyens mais derrière
il ya 17 machines
il y a le conseil comme vous disais donc
tout ça c'est avait cessé avec la
nécessité de mener est mais je ne
conclurai formé comme les institutions
la commission elle lance une conférence
sur l'avenir de l'europe pour se pencher
une nouvelle fois sur le fonctionnement
l'union
les citoyens européens est ce qu ils
doivent y être associés comment
manuellement par a pleinement oui
pleinement ils doivent y être associés
parce que je pense qu'il ya un sentiment
de défiance dans un certain nombre
d'états membres aujourd'hui entre les
citoyens et la construction européenne
donc cette conférence
elle peut être une bonne nouvelle si
elle n'écarte aucun sujet et si elle ne
se traduit pas à la fin par quelques
modifications cosmétiques
c'est à dire que si à la fin ça permet
juste d'instaurer le principe des listes
transnationales j'y suis pas opposé mais
si c'est juste ça la réponse je pense
pas qu'on résoudra le problème il faut
aller plus loin a renforcé le pouvoir
d'initiative citoyenne en europe
renforcer le rôle du parlement
aujourd'hui a quand même pas le pouvoir
d'initiative législative c'est l'un des
seuls parlements
c'est dans le monde qui a passées au
pouvoir l'a donc je pense qu'il faut
aller sur des modifications radicales et
ses modifications radicales
elle passe nécessairement dans mon point
de vue par la modification des traités
et boxer la conférence elle pose cette
question d
était alors elle peut être utile il faut
se ressaisir au niveau européen avant
les grands projets et se met tous
ensemble pressé de réaliser jeudi la
machine à freiner c'est surtout le
conseil alors le parlement on n'a
peut-être pas le pouvoir d'initiative on
a un vrai pouvoir de codécision je vous
dis moi je travaillais sur les marchés
publics c'était michel barnier à la
manoeuvre à la commission un moment on a
vraiment une lutte qui a duré six mois
entre le parlement et le conseil
on n'a presque pas avancer sauf à la fin
et où on a on a tenus sur des positions
et les exemples sont comme ça multiples
c'est trop peu connue des citoyens se
seront elle aimait la fin merci être les
trois d'être venu sur ce plateau
vous pouvez voir et revoir cette
émission replay sur le site internet de
public sénat mais aussi sur l'antenne de
la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures urbaines
[Musique]